la sexualisation elle est bien dans sa
tenue elle est bien dans sa vie et on va
la briser déjà briser en allant à
l'école comme ça
regarde la photo allez on soutien-gorge
avec un truc vert on voit son c'est
c'est descend pour les à l'école ça
c'est comme ça normal c'est c'est normal
elle est couvert elle est couverte d'où
là elle est à poil et aller à poil mais
pour moi l'école il y a une tenue il y a
un respect il y a de la bienséance il y
a des codes sociaux c'est pas Pattaya
c'est pas un but tu vois c'est pas une
règle bizarre donc je pense que cette
tenue est totalement inappropriée je
trouve qu'elle a eu raison d'être enfin
le chef d'établissement a eu raison de
la dégager et la même manière alors à ce
moment-là le chef le prof il va arriver
en paréo et en tong et on dirait bah
ouais finalement tout ça c'est cool tout
train d'être dévoyé c'est mon corps ça
m'appartient j'ai le droit de faire
n'importe quoi c'est bon si vous voulez
effectivement c'est l'école c'est un
lieu d'éducation elle est très jolie
c'est pas le problème mais effectivement
elle est en soutif effectivement on voit
son ventre on sait que le ventre c'est
très joli un ventre plat c'est un truc
de séduction mais j'ai qu'une question
tu laisses ta fille elle est à l'école
comme ça